welcome to this video Baffler better
know I've never played him before from
the US let's see
Vienna again Bishop this game this kind
of thing therefore in this position
that's not a good move but I have
forgotten wine i him nope I cannot take
them 94 mm why is this bad there is a
reason why this is not good
taking on g1 taking on e4 maybe I cannot
remember d6 is not the reason d5 is also
d5 maybe brah
this is sometimes the problem with those
kind of yeah to be honest bedside lines
for white I mean they are they are bad
but when they get played against you in
blitz chess it's sometimes difficult to
remember why exactly they are bad and
then you spend spend time 9422 maybe
I can play Queenie to my unless to mated
that move come on
this is also not bad I was just I'm just
kind of not remembering how exactly I
punish this wait maybe yes some weird
division zoo Queen age five or something
great stuff
okay now he's threatening on f7 made so
yeah yeah g6 Queen e5 is sure probably
not a good idea
okay I probably have to cancel and of
course this is not the refutation of
this with the stuff that you played
quite clearly not it's always always
annoying if they play this kind of
nonsense and you forget all to refute it
f4 is just bad 55 okay I have to check
here to check afterwards normal mu C
just is better now this is the problem
really and he will get in
early early castles as well long castles
yeah it should be seven maybe this might
before
you can just take a farm and planning
night before then night before we should
be three Bishop e6 something like that
that's not really great of course but
you know I wanted to take on a father
that's not working and maybe I can take
on a 494 Bishop g1 maybe that's a
refutation I don't know
is allowing me to take her okay okay so
this is now the worst is definitely over
it's still not good but at least I'm not
this is an end game yeah with with
opposite colored bishops it it could be
worse
now it's still clearly better with this
pawn that I felt like it could be worse
good news is that he is spending some
time here and not playing so quickly
yeah I really have to check this opening
afterwards
yeah here I mean the opposite colored
bishops always not always but here they
do increase the hope for a draw for
black but it's still very much better
for whitey I'm simply due to the fact
that he has this he has more space at
the better structure this is the most
important thing not so much the number
of pawns but the structure is very
helpful for him ok maybe I can get one
pawn traded yeah opposite colored
bishops drawing tend to give a drawing
tendency but with rooks on the board
it's not that that clear that did help
it's helpful so much so I will go a form
get rid of one of the weaknesses here
and he he has Luke a 1 but Luke traits I
mean I don't mind rope traits that much
try to come over to the Queen side where
he has all those pawns so it seems like
he wants to trade wants to trade ok this
is after the after the trade my drawing
chance is increasing quite clearly this
is the way to do it attack the pawns
yeah this makes it difficult Fame to
advance them and if possible I want to
make sure that he's not getting
connected pawns this looks possible at
the moment so let's see I'm just staying
here you can't run a high point on I
should make sure that that's not so
quickly happening so how to do it if he
gets to be six I can go to c8 so it's
not okay
king b6 is varying me a little bit not
pawn to b6 this is definitely a draw
okay this is a draw we should be 7 to c8
I'm just staying there forever
maybe he can can enter via five maybe
but I don't think it's that much of a
problem
and I can run all the way to age seven
maybe it's still a loss mmm that's not
good yeah unbelievable I was really
thinking this is a drawback white
forfeits on time I really don't know
what I did there but I just won the game
what there's some kind of stunt this is
a kind of a self trap here I mean this
it what is this what kind of position is
this it arose purely purely by chance
this is a draw due to f4 I'm not
believing it
the compass giving this is zero zero
zero Wow kay takes g5 yeah I mean I'm
getting this counterplay and what he
what he needs to do is here here he has
to play b7 now this is losing and
promoting after that Wow he has to do
this and now quickly switch this back
edge to here here and this is this is
quite clearly a draw I mean check and
the draw Wow
so here I'm all of a sudden I'm winning
yeah can you believe that and somehow I
got the Primo zento to win ha
I'm baffled his name is kind of fitting
Bella ok I want to I really want to
recheck this opening fYI is really not
good but I forgot why I'm the computer
is not giving anything sense since that
makes it makes any sense
it gives d6 which is not terrible but
just transposes to the declined king's
gambit I think f4 is not good but why I
D 3 is normal preparing f4 but I thought
f4 has a drawback maybe I'm seeing those
and it's not that terrible I don't know
I thought you always has to play d3
first and I thought there is some tactic
connected to that there are some things
that you can can think of yeah I mean
even this is not not completely
ridiculous this is kind of idea but he
always has this move funny funny stuff
ok I went here here 94 is good ok and
this is also good yeah I mean this is
the kind of thing where you calculate
start to calculate in a blitz game and
you think okay is this really working
like this I can cancel actually ok g3
this is what I was seeing and I kind of
stopped after Queen takes e5 and I
thought oh wow
better not maybe this is just not so
great as it looks for wide
yeah nobody knows this is possible
computer gives this gentleman so that's
really funny with the point to play that
if I take or if he takes a double check
check then you get check this funny
funny thing and again I have no idea
what's going on but there doesn't seem
to be something clear but okay
Here I am what should take 90 FOIA and
this this was yeah I have to play many
c6 first this is this is now this is now
leading to some trouble I really play
badly I missed that one funny double
check yeah this is why I always
recommend to to younger players of
starting out players why they should if
they don't object play a 45 yeah I'm not
forcing people to play anything but
there's so many tactics and interesting
complications that can come up that you
really learn to calculate better and I
honestly think if I was started to play
e5 earlier and my in my chess career it
would have helped me to be a better
calculator but I didn't start with
something else okay well I hope you
enjoyed it was a fun game at least
thanks for watching